seit heute werden ja in großbritannien
soldaten dafür eingesetzt die
tankstellen mit sprit zu versorgen denn
tankstellen sind leer die die die regale
von supermärkten sind leer eine direkte
folge des praxis fehlen in
großbritannien um die 400.000 lkw-fahrer
weil man eben viele osteuropäer vor
allem polen vergrault hat aus dem land
gedrängt hat nun fehlen sie
ich
[Musik]
beobachte das fasziniert deshalb weil
ich die gegenseite dieser ganzen
geschichte hier in deutschland erlebe es
ja nicht nur so dass der präsident
dritten schadet sondern eher schadet uns
ja auch hier selbst man kann wozu macht
man so beobachtungen ich hab jetzt
gemacht ich fahre ein englisches auto
einen range rover evoque den finde ich
ganz deutlich auf
wenn ich ihn fahren könnte wären aber
dieses auto steht jetzt seit 14 wochen
in der werkstatt 14 wochen und wird
nicht repariert weil ein ersatzteil aus
england nicht her kommt und ja und dann
habe ich mich dann mit der werkstatt
meine das ist keine kleine klitschen das
ist die größte range rover werkstatt und
der größte range rover händler in berlin
am kurfürstendamm also weiter geht's
nicht
dann rufe ich bei denen immer wieder an
und sage run und run könnte nennen das
ersatzteil kommen seit 14 wochen haben
die letzte auskunft war vielleicht ende
november auch das ist die wirklichkeit
bei britt vielleicht im november ich
fahre mit carsharing um ja denn sie
stellen wir ja auch keiner satz auto
also die haben den hof voller
gebrauchtwagen stehen
auch noch die sie zahlen wir gar nicht
sie geben mir auch nichts sie sagen die
kosten für das ersatzauto zahlt der
hersteller nicht und wir als händler
machen schon mal gar nicht es war
eigentlich das jetzt entschuldigung wenn
ich das in rechnung stellen da muss ich
einfach sagen der praxis hat die
verhältnisse grundlegend verändert und
ich kann alle nur auffordern kaufen sie
kein britisches auto
der grund ist natürlich nicht rein weiß
ich dass es so
weit ist schon ja also ich dachte
natürlich bei olivias habe mir überlegt
was hat er vielleicht für ein auto ein
englisches auto finde ich ganz ganz
spannend und range rover ist auch mein
traum ich finde ich super bis zum pass
ist dass du den first dog ist glaube ich
dieser ganz besonders schnittigen
gibt es
also in hörbare kombination jetzt weiß
ich aber glaube ich auch dass der range
rover natürlich ein traditionelles
britisches auto ist erst in den 70ern
schon begonnen hat als echter
geländewagen auch jetzt wieder so die
tradition als gelesen kommt defender
zurück ja man könnte und allerdings ist
er vor einigen jahren ich glaub schon
vor mehr als zehn jahren übernommen
wurden indischen unternehmen tatra oder
sonst ein eigentümer jetzt frage ich
mich natürlich hängt das wirklich mit
dem brett zusammen ja ist dass er ich
hatte mal einen chefredakteur
tatsächlich einen ganz tollen mann der
hat er ein jaguar und
war deswegen darf man sich jetzt sind
wir jetzt sehr und er erkennt das muss
man sagen ob schönes auto
wo sich einfach ergeben
dass meine sagte ich hatte immer platz
eigentlich für nette begleiterinnen
hatte ich aber nie weil da saß immer
nämlich abgekauft ich habe
für die heimat machen ein ganz wichtiger
bentley zu zulieferer sedlmeier in
ostthüringen ganz wichtig
dass alles noch am weg
[Gelächter]
zurück zum break wir sehen natürlich
großmutter mindest absolutes desaster
was ist die menschen dort versprochen
worden wählt den drag city seid frei von
aller vorschriften aus brüssel
ihr könnt euch frei entfalten ihr könnt
euer unternehmertum wieder leben ihr
habt alles was sie braucht und noch viel
mehr als in der vergangen jetzt haben
gesagt noch nicht mal mehr sprit sie
haben keine
lkw fahrer die ihnen die regale
auffüllen es ist noch schlimmer als
während der krone lockdown zeit wir
sehen natürlich unsere volkswirtschaften
sind ineinander verschränkt durch die
globalisierung der immer noch anhält und
die briten waren fest eingewoben in das
europäische staaten gefüge und das was
du erlebst hat natürlich
wesentliche folgen nicht nur für dich
sondern auch für die menschen dort im
bus weiß ja dass ich nicht alleine bin
mit dem schicksal das weiß ich ja da
sagt man ja auch die werkstatt für sie
glauben sie nicht dass sie alleine sind
es die der der hersteller übrigens tata
dass der aus indien kommt sagt nichts
über die qualität der autos dies
hervorragend ich habe wegen taten
niemals zweifel an der marke
gehört eigentlich in denen das heißt
ihnen gar nichts ich muss noch
nachtragen was wenn ersatzteil
eigentlich fehlt man könnte jetzt denken
das ist ein kompliziertes elektronisches
teil da gibt's ja moment enorme probleme
in der autoindustrie aber dass überhaupt
kein mikro chip drin es ist nämlich
einfach eingestanzt es stück blech
gestanzt und gepresst es ist eine
motorhaube die kriegen also einer
motorhaube nicht von england hierher
mehr als in der langen zeit einmal
erklärt worden kommt ende august am 31
august nach bedford was immer ein
bedford ist irgendwann zwischenlager und
wird dann von dort weiter verschifft
dann habe ich schon gehört schiff geht
das einordnen chefs über das nicht mal
geflogen oder man lkw gefahren sehr
merkwürdig der august ging vorbei jetzt
hör ich könnte ende november sein könnte
vielleicht ende november sein ich frage
mich ob ich das auto in jedem jahr
überhaupt noch wiedersehe und wenn ich
es dann wieder sie überhaupt noch lust
habe das ding zu fahren
carsharing ist gar nicht schlecht muss
ich
bin nach
aber ohne das einzige was man an diesem
beispiel sieht was ja gar nicht so
schlecht ist auch wenn es dich jetzt
trifft meine hatte er lange jetzt das
gefühl der bei exit bliebe ohne folgen
also wie lange das gefühl kommt
ungeschoren davon das wäre dann fast so
wie in deutschland kann es auch machen
ich kann man schon die ersten politiker
ihr vor ständig sagen der praxis
funktioniert ganz toll wozu brauchen wir
europa und deswegen glaube ich merkt man
daran ja auch vielleicht ein hinweis auf
unsere zuschauer man sollte vor
weihnachten nichts aus england bestehen
und nicht mehr ankommt uns bestimmt
nicht und man kann sich doch vorstellen
was in einer fabrik los ist die die
maschinen aus england genutzt und da
geht irgendwann geht irgendein teil
kaputt und wir brauchen ein ersatzteil
geht sonja anders als mir und das müssen
ja keine komplizierten sachen sein das
kann ein bestimmter spezialbohrer sein
irgendetwas fehlt und du kriegst es
nicht also wir erleben jetzt wie nicht
nur der britische import nahrungsmittel
tch zusammengebrochen ist die regale
sind leer sondern der export ist dabei
auch noch zusammenzubrechen und herr
johnson sitzt der premierminister und
erzählt die lustigsten geschichten um
seine richtung exit leute bei laune zu
halten jetzt hat euch ein parteitag hat
den leuten gerade erzählt aber jetzt
werden die löhne steigen
verein werden wer glaubt denn das wenn
die wirtschaft probleme hat und außerdem
selbst wenn sie steigen würden was
kaufen die dann davon auf einer nahen
und apfel sehen können sie nicht mehr
kaufen hat erst mal versucht zu erklären
dass das ja in den anderen ländern
gerade auch so schlimm ist mit dem
benzin das fand ich ja ganz irre als ich
das gelesen habe dann haben die leute
nach nordirland übergeben da läuft das
komischerweise gehört auch zu
großbritannien und das ist ja das irre
und deswegen finde ich das so richtig
was du gesagt hast nena dass dieser dass
der brechtsche tatsächlich auswirkungen
haben dass die briten merken welches
reise sicht dargelegt haben das ist
glaube ich ganz ganz wichtig mit blick
auf den europäischen zusammen rat nur
wir tragen glaube ich alle ein bisschen
eine mitschuld an dem braig cit ich habe
in england
wir haben wir haben wir haben london
nicht nicht wir haben die engländer
nicht so genommen wie sie sind sie sind
die älteste demokratie der welt sie sind
eine eine rechts verfassung sie haben
sie sind individualistisch und sie haben
brüssel nicht anerkannt als die
wegweisende behörde die alles für sie
auch auf der insel und das regeln sollte
und dass auch unser anspruch von helmut
kohl dann aber auch alle weiteren
die wollten das eben wir mit dem
europäischen markt auch alle
befindlichkeiten in großbritannien das
letzte wort
[Musik]